God, we're gonna blow each other up so many times..
*laughing*
Tyler: No, you can't hurt each other, but you can blow yourself ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mark: I can blow myself?! What? That's the greatest day of my life!!!
Woah, Egg Launcher??? What the fuck is an Egg Launcher..?
Tyler: All right, so it's very fitting that we go to Flush.
Mark: If we don't g- land in Tilted Towers, I'm gonna cut your dick off! (woah, there, Mark)
Tyler: All right, we're going to-
Mark: No, we don't have to go to Tilted!
I know that threat sounds very imposing!
*Tyler laughs*
I hope I'm going to the right place. Also, are you saying we should go to Flush because
we are giant pieces of shit, is that what you're saying?
Tyler: Yeah, well... No, but...
Yes at the same time.
*SHOTS FIRED*
Mark: *dead* Woah, woah, woah, woah, that came outta nowhere
NO! *KAB00M*
Ohh, shhhhit
Tyler: Uhh, I take it they took you out.
Mark: yea ;-;
Tyler: Yeah, you didn't land at Flush
Mark: Wha- where was Flush? Wait, were we in the wro-
OHHHH
I was not even in the right city.
See, this is why I was supposed to cut your dick off!
So you were all like *strange Markimoo noises*
and I was all like "DUH DUH DUUHHH"
Tyler, if you don't get one kill we're all cuttin your dick off.
Do it, do it man, do it man
Yaaahahaahaha
Yay, you get to keep your dick!
More kills equals more DICC
Tyler: I'm fightin to- to keep percentages.
Mark: No, no it's like every kill you get one inch to save, so you're good!
*Tyler and Mark both laugh*
Tyler: One inch is better than no inch.
All right, I believe in you. You're the best. You're wonderful. You're a beautiful human being
Can't wait to... see you succeed in life
Everything that you have going for you is... great. You're a shining beacon of humanity. You're handsome
You've...got...umm... (Tyler:) You're being very distracting right now...
*Mark and Tyler laugh*
M: (imitating Tyler) Shut the fuck up with your compliments, I am concentrating here, I know I'm handsome you shut your goddamn ugly mouth!
Oh yeah there there. Oh, you're in trouble. Nice dodge!
T: All right, let's fill our squad here.
M: Yea, Let's do that let's definitely do that
T: Does that mean we should switch off at Discord and into the game chat so that they could talk to us too?
M: I mean I guess if we really want to. Wait now our teammates are gonna be all kinds of like *strange voice * UUGH SHUT UP
Tyler: I don't believe that. Not for one second.
M: They might! You know, my voice is not very enticing! People hear my voice they want to punch me! it's a p-curse!
M: I can't FELP it.
T: Is that like fapping but with felt?
M: YES! I can't fap my way through this problem, man!
Wanna a fucking blow *pause*  up *gibberish*
T: You wanna blow yourself?
M: I WANNA BLOW
M: God if I could...
*laughs*
If I could man, you don't understand what I hope and pray for every single night before I go to bed *breaks off into laughter*
T: Oh, geez *bursts into laughter*
T: Just please take out some vertebrae give me that flexibility!
*Laughter*
T: Is it is it a vertebrae or ribs? Just, you're asking-(Mark:) BOTH! Take out whatever you can! LORD ABOVE
M: Please! Just- just make my head at crotch level please! *Tyler bursts into laughter*
M: Oh my god everyone else is here. I'm sorry teammates. I'm sorry.
Random man: OH MAH GOD IT'S REAL MARKIPLIER
Mark: It is! Yes, it is.
Are-where are we going? T: Where are we going?
*silence*
M: Tilted, alright, here we go! *Mark and Tyler laugh*
Mark: IT'S JUST EXPLOSIONS
M: WHAT THE F**K IS HAPPENING!?!?
*Tyler and Mark both shout Gibberish*
T: YES! I GOT 'EM, MARK!
M: *screams*
M: Dude..Dude, you don't know how hard I'm trying right now..
M: AAH I GOT 'EM! GET F**KED!!!
M: Who was that!?
M: Who? Where? What? Why, and how?
M: There? I don't know...
*Tyler and Mark both start laughing again*
*Various shouts and Mark yelling "I got it" twice*
M: GET ME UP! HELP ME, PLS!
*kaboom*
*Tyler and Mark both laugh*
M: How did I-?
M: How did I eliminate myself? *Tyler laughing in background*
M: no! No! COME ON, NO!
M: No, I knocked myself out! Please...
M: I'm gonna stick my head so far up your ass. (ew, gross, Mark)
M: You're so worried! Oh did I-*Markimoo noises*
*Ferocious Markimoo battle cry*
M: NOOO! T: Oh, noo. M: BUT I GOT 'EM!
T: Oh, this is right over Tilted. M: Oh hell yeah, you know it's gonna be good.
T: There are sooo many people that are ready to DIE immediately *Mark laughs*
M: I'm ready to die. Tyler, wait! I'm coming to you! I'm coming baby boi!
T: Oh, I'm dead! M: oh, baby boy...
M: *laughs* baby boi, no!
M: Baby! My baby boy! T: I didn't get the killsss!!!!!! M: (talking over Tyler) ooh, your dick is gone. :(
*intense concentration from Markimoo*
T: You got-you got the sweet small shields. Too bad it's not a medi-*Mark screams*
M: F**king WHYY!
*Tyler laughs like a donkey and Mark laughs like he's crying*
M: I'm sorry. I got-I was SHOOK! *while laughing* I didn't know what was happening...
M: Alright, hang on. I can't-If I go out in the open I'm-I'm DOOMED!
M: E-SHIBOOM!
*various complaints from both Mark and Tyler because Mark missed*
M: BOOM! YEAH! T: YOU GOT 'EM!
M: I got you, bitch! I got you!
*Even more Markimoo sounds*
M: Yeah, I got him. Okay, that's one.
M: eeeyeeeyeeyee.
M: Oh, I see you!
*Tyler shouting at the top of his lungs, warning Mark of his impending doom*
M: *SCREAMS* AAH, I DIDN'T SEEE IT!
*disappointed laugh*
T: I feel like the entire time we're just screaming (yes, you are)
M: I'm pretty sure. Like, is there anything-there's nothing different in any of my other videos, so *while laughing* why would it be any different here?
M: Here we go! Let's go for it! Let's do this!!!!
M: I GOT A GUIDED!
*Mark blows up, and then screams because he didn't expect it*
M: *high pitched voice* NOOOO! WHO DID THAAAT! NOOOOOO I GOT A GUIDED!
M: *in a shrill scream* F**CK YOOOUUUUU!
M: let me try to barter with this guy. WOAH, well, that's a guided missile that-
M: What the f**k? *various indignant Markimoo sounds*
M: ah! Uh oh, that's not good! AH!
M: Take this! Take-and this! And some of that! *gets blown up* NOOOOOOOO
M: My C-4's on the ground! *while sobbing* IT DIDN'T GO OFF
T: Yeah the eggs are a pai-our guy-okay, he's just..dancing..
M: wtf... *laughs with Tyler*
*Even more laughs. Oho, so funny. Much laughter*
M: ber-dur-de-de-der!
*random kid in chat starts talking unintelligibly.*
M: oh my god, who is that?
*Kid starts speaking again, but a bit louder*
T: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE SAYYYING!
Mark: I don't, either, man!
M: It's just as comprehensible as our yelling, I guess. Uh oh, that's a guided...
M: *kid is still talking* OH NO! OH NO! NO! PLEASE!
M: Come at me. (x3) *dramatic chord* Come at me (x2)
M: NO! I WAS WATCHING THE HOMING!
M: *in low, gravelly voice* Ah, let's do this. *slaps hands together*
M: We got this. *makes strange sound*
T: Are you slapping yourself right now?
M: No, I'm-I'm jerking off. (ew) T: Oh, okay.
M: You remember back in our wrestling days when I would get psyched out all by myself. (Tyler starts protesting with various "woahs" in the background)
*keeps slapping hands together* (you're gross, Markimoo)
M: I'm gonna go out there and I'ma wrestle real good! *Tyler laughs*  You remember. We would do it together! To each other! You don't remember that?
*silence*
*Tyler says something unintelligible, but it sounds indignant*
M: Do you remember watching me? Oh yeah, that's right. You remember watching me alone in the showers.
M: I'm gonna do a sick maneuver.
M: Are you ready? Okay, here we go. I don't know how this works. I've neVER-YAH-HUH! (Tyler:) WOAH!
Mark and Tyler: OH NOO!
*Mark dies as Tyler once again laughs like a donkey*
*Tyler keeps laughing while Markimoo covers his face in embarrassment*
M: Guys, guys. Everyone in chat. Guys, guys, listen, listen, listen, listen, listen. You're un-subbing, I understand.
*giggles*
M: Hang on, wait. Hang on, hold up!
M: Listen. (pls)
M I... am not good *laughs* at... this game.
M: But. BUT! Butt. We all knew that!
M: It's like when I said at PAX in the panel. You got to start at rock bottom and believe in yourself *laughs*
You got to keep trying! No matter what, you got to get back on the horse!
M: *mutters about his "pro-ness"*
M: OOOOhhh, gotcha! *wails*
*Tyler rambling in the background* M:I can't shoot out-wait. I could-I can make a window. Hang on, I'll make a window, and then I'll make a ceiling.
And I'll shoot out the window. Watch this.
T & M: Oh, yeah.
M: Oh yeah, I'm coming in all low. Alright.
T: You're in the rocket.
M: 'Progameralf'. Oh, we're coming for you, baby.
M: Oh, it's happening. It's happening, baby. *explosions*
M: Oh! *pause* YEAHHHHH WE GOT HIM YEAAH (Tyler:) Yeah!
oh, baby. Oh, baby. OH, BABY,  A TRIPLE!
*Mark laughs*
M: Yeah this seems ridiculously overpowered. How is this-how is this like still okay? Is that my dude? (x3)
M: Hey dude. *bursts into laughter*
M: He didn't get the roof on in time. I got him.
T: Right there! (Mark:) I see okay. Well. This is gonna be a-(Tyler interrupts:) back to where he went.
M: This is gonna be a trip.
*Mark starts making a weird noise*
M: *Sounds of protest* Oh, the tree! F**K!
M: Don't worry. I got you covered Claw-de. (what?)
M: He's still in that bush? Yep!
*Tyler and Mark both laugh*
T: I'm also gonna have to move in the circle in 40-something seconds.
M: I got a jump pad, I'll be fine.
T: oh. MOVE, YOU'RE GETTING SHOT!
M: NO! (x4)
M: *sobbing* noo!
M: Maybe-maybe 'Progameralf' can get me. But probably not. (Tyler:) NOOOOO
*Mark screams, then dissolves into laughter*
*Upbeat outro music plays* I hope anyone who needs these subtitles is happy with my work! I hope I did good! Subscribe to Markiplier, he's awesome!
*music*